you guys know Byron Donald's I think
he's a he's a massive Republican star on
the way up had him on the show a couple
times from Southwest Florida Congressman
here uh just across the state uh he went
on uh wolf blitzer's program on uh CNN
and watch this as Byron just lays out
the nonsensical case against Trump look
at Wolf's face the whole time it's
pretty Priceless they don't even cite
the actual felony charge they're saying
it has something to do with the 2016
elections he was trying to subvert the
elections in some new uh crazy scheme
they're citing uh bookkeeping in the
state of New York as the layup into
these these these Fel these felony
charges but they actually don't cite the
charge so what are you supposed to do
with that I mean it's clear that Alvin
Bragg had was on a mission to indict
Donald Trump and so that's how we got to
where we are but you say 34 felonies but
what are we actually talking about what
are the actual charges
speak to it the prosecutors argue in
this indictment that Trump's goal was to
hide damaging information that's a
direct quote damaging information from
American voters just ahead of the 2016
election doesn't that concern you
um timeout at what point is trying to
either actually let me here's a better
question for you wolf Hillary Clinton
spents a million dollars on a fake
dossier citing that he was a Russian
plant we all know that to be true so
it's okay to spend a million dollars of
campaign cash to create a phony dossier
to secrete through the media to tilt the
2020 to 2016 elections but now we're
going to say that there are booking a
regular irregularities about an NDA
agreement between him and somebody else
and that's now hiding stuff from the
people I mean this is a joke it's a
ridiculous this is
a campaign these were campaign
violations what he was trying to do uh
in paying off a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars uh to uh Stormy Daniels
wolf even the FEC looked at this and the
FEC said there's nothing to see here the
Department of Justice looked at this
they said there's nothing to see here
last time I checked Alvin Bragg does not
sit on the FEC he's not somebody who
steeped in election law he's a local
prosecutor in Manhattan where by the way
he's actually downgraded of violent
felonies in Manhattan to the people of
Manhattan aren't as safe as they should
be in their own streets that is not even
his jurisdiction so he piles that into
this indictment which frankly doesn't
even really cite what he's talking about
except the 2016 elections and we're
supposed to sit here and take this
seriously no this is politics and it's
gross politics this is the type of thing
that the American people don't want to
see look you can have disagreements
between Republicans and Democrats I have
strong opinions of my own but to say
that you're going to shoot home some
shoe horn some phony situation into a
felony indictment or 34 felony
indictments that is a stretch that is a
kangaroo court you can see Wolf Blitzer
like choking in his vomit as he's doing
that
[Music]
foreign